thank you for rejoining us after a very
fine lunch
this is Hillsdale after all and we can
always count on a very great meal and to
be well fed now my name is Chris Moran
I'm the executive director of the Acton
Institute from Grand Rapids Michigan and
I've had the distinct honor and
privilege to be involved in this free
market forum since its inception so I
want to thank Hillsdale for once again
inviting my participation and of course
to the Darrell foundation I know Dave is
somewhere in the audience for supporting
this splendid educational effort now our
topic for this panel is in the form of a
question
dodd-frank repeal and replace question
mark now in the case that that delicious
meal is making you sleepy or you get an
emergency phone call let me give you the
answer to the question yes repeal
and as for replace why would we do that
well well because again this is
Hillsdale I know that 99% that this room
is better educated on economics and
public policy than 99% of America you
probably all know what dodd-frank is but
for a few of you may you may need a
refresher and I can summarize it in this
way it is two thousand two hundred and
fifty three pages of regulations now the
bill was written in the aftermath of the
financial meltdown of 2007-2008 which
itself was brought about in no small
part from errant regulations and bad
government policies naturally our
politicians rushed to the rescue and
delivered us the misleadingly named
dodd-frank Wall Street Reform and
Consumer Protection Act which neither
reforms Wall Street nor protects
consumers have I left anything for you
guys to say okay well nonetheless to
help us untangle the mess that is
dodd-frank and why it's important to
each of you we have three expert
panelists today and I will introduce
them all here at the beginning invite
them to the stage one by one following
the other and following their short
remarks we will invite QA from the floor
so let me begin with someone in my far
right that I've only just had the
pleasure to meet Peter Wallison now
Peter everybody I've talked to has told
me you're a stand-up guy but don't let
the fact that he's from Washington has
worked in government and as a lawyer
throw you
in fact his background is a former
general counsel for the Treasury
Department and also counsel to Ronald
Reagan yes go get and the president
holder of the Arthur F burns chair and
financial market studies that AEI makes
him highly qualified to diagnose the
problems with dodd-frank
he's written at least two books on the
financial crisis including his latest
book hidden in plain sight what caused
the world's worst financial crisis and
why it could happen again
now following Peter to his left we'll
hear from Paul Atkins like Peter his
background in government as a lawyer
could be worrisome but I can attest
personally that Paul is a stand-up guy
that I've known for more than 20 years I
first met Paul's wife in 1986 I think
before you met her at a small
libertarian cabal she's solid you
married well now I've had the pleasure
as well to be with his family on a
number of occasions which includes three
impressive young men now on the
professional side I can't think of
anyone more credible and knowledgeable
about regulating the financial sector
than Paul Atkins his early career as a
attorney with price waterhouse Cooper
was as an expert consultant on
regulatory compliance internal controls
and risk management and tell of his
appointment as an SEC Commissioner in
2002 where he served honorably for two
terms talk about knowing how the sausage
is made now Paul has a solid and
well-deserved reputation as a regulation
killer and if we have to have a
government I'll rest easier knowing that
people of Paul's ideological commitments
courage and tenacity are in the mix that
is why I was especially encouraged when
Donald Trump was elected and reached out
to Paul to help him identify key
opportunities for financial deregulation
and to identify key individuals
who could execute those reforms indeed
The Wall Street Journal called Paul
Donald Trump's point man on financial
regulation since leading the leaving the
SEC in 2008 Paul founded a very
successful consulting company called
Potomac global partners with offices in
Washington and New York and if starting
a real business and employing people
isn't redemptive enough Paul should also
get credit as an excellent judge of fine
wine and beer now our final panelist to
my left is Nicole Gelinas now Nicole
didn't know this until this panel but
we're cousins it's true our common
ancestor 18 Gallinas we might have said
back then
gilina arrived in New France in 1658 at
the time there were very few families in
Quebec and the total population was well
under 5,000 so while indeed we are
related probably two-thirds of Canada
could say that too but nonetheless
Etienne de Lynas was a sturdy stock
imagine making a two-month voyage across
the Atlantic in 1658 and if that wasn't
enough landing into the undeveloped
wilds surrounded by hostile Iroquois
Indians who were oddly not grateful for
civilization having been brought to them
Etienne was brave and courageous and
those traits have survived to this day
in abundance in Nikol who never shai's
from the strong articulation of
free-market principles and policymaking
Nicole is a senior fellow at the
Manhattan Institute a contributing
editor of the city journal and a
columnist at the New York Post
she writes regularly on urban economics
and finance
she is a CFA charterholders and an
author most recently of the book after
the fall saving capitalism from Wall
Street and Washington please join me in
welcoming our distinguished panel
[Applause]
wonderful to be here and I love the
title of this panel repeal or and
replace or or replace obviously it is
this law is so devastating to our
economy that the question of replacement
is not even relevant here the the
significant thing is that it was not
necessary to begin with the if many of
you have attended other of these forums
where I have spoken on the housing
policies of the US government which did
cause the financial crisis you know that
the lack of regulation of the financial
system was not the cause and so if we
could repeal dodd-frank I'm afraid it
doesn't look that way in Washington
right now but if we could repeal
dodd-frank we would not have to replace
it with anything because in fact we
didn't need dodd-frank in any sense I
want to be sure that my this thing is
working because I do have some slides
and before I get started
hmm see I always have trouble with these
these gadgets so it came up okay good
well let's talk a little bit about the
cost to the economy of dodd-frank there
are really several elements in the in
the law that have caused or will cause
severe problems for the US economy now
they in the 20 minutes that they have a
lot of me here which I've used almost to
they are they are not going to be
something I cannot cover them all but
I'll try to cover what I think is the
main one but mention a few at the
beginning one of the major problems with
it is the great uncertainty
that it causes for the business
community and that's because of several
different things that are in the act
one is the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau which many of you have heard
about which has the ability to prosecute
consumer people who market to consumers
for something called abuse of consumers
that's the term in the statute however
it's not defined and the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau refuses to
define what they mean by abuse if I can
get this off no that didn't work there
we are because I think you might it's I
was sitting in the back in this morning
and it's actually hard to see the
speaker up here so I thought I'd get my
picture back on the screen the the after
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
there's a financial stability Oversight
Council which has the ability to
designate certain large firms as
systemically important financial
institutions and when they are so
designated they are delivered over to
the Federal Reserve for what is called
stringent regulation one of the first to
be so designated was GE Capital which
was one of the most successful lenders
to smaller businesses smaller growing
businesses in the United States and GE
took one look at what was happening to
GE Capital under the regulation of the
Federal Reserve and said forget it guys
we're getting out and the way they did
that was just to reduce GE capital from
a lender to the market in general to a
lender for general electric's products
enough with GE capital so we've suffered
a tremendous loss there another
regulation you've probably heard of is
called the Volcker Rule the Volcker Rule
has
push the banks out of doing a lot of
market making with the result that
there's much less liquidity in the
markets that we need I happen to believe
that if we ever have anything close to
another crisis like situation there
won't be enough liquidity so that people
can actually cash out on many of the
investments that that they have made and
theirs as a result this is likely to be
a cause of another financial crisis but
the most significant thing in the
dodd-frank act is its effect on small
banks and I will cover that in detail
because in my view that is the principal
cause of the very weak recovery from the
2008 financial crisis and the ensuing
recession in 2009 and the very weak
recovery we've had since the recession
ended in 2009 and the right through the
end of the Obama presidency the
dodd-frank is the only plausible reason
for this slow recovery the US economy is
a giant multifaceted organism that
cannot easily be stopped or suppressed
anything capable of doing so would have
to be very large and probably only
something that can be done by the
government during the Obama
administration there were only four
major policies that could qualify for
this role you've heard of them all I'm
sure the economic Recovery Act which
sprinkled eight hundred billion dollars
for shovel-ready projects that was one
the Affordable Care Act which has been
in the news this past year was the
second and the third that I'd like to
just mention is the Fed's quantitative
easing program which reduced interest
rates to close to zero all three of
those should have been extraordinarily
stimulative for the economy they were
not why because there was a fourth and
that is the dodd-frank act this imposed
strict new financial regulations which
overcame all of the stimulative efforts
that are the likely source of the
economy's and and is the likely source
of the economy's suppressed growth the
chart on the screen let's see if I can
get it back up there there it is the
chart on the screen shows the weakness
of the recovery from the start of the
last recession in June of 2009 through
2013 s prepared by the Federal Reserve
Bank of Dallas now the red line at the
bottom is this recovery the black line
going through the shaded area is the
average of all other recovery since the
middle 1960s so you see this one is
there really is a is really an outlier
and what we have to do is try to explain
why it was now my view as I expressed
already is that the it was the result of
the dodd-frank act as the chart shows
through the first quarter of 2013
there has been some modest economic
growth if far less than in the normal
recovery in fact an average growth rate
of somewhat less than 2% occurred
through 2013 and then through the end of
the Obama term is there then a plausible
connection between this slow growth and
the dodd-frank act I will try to try to
show that there is and it comes through
the cost burdens that had been imposed
on small banks in developing and
adopting the dodd-frank act Congress and
the administration did not appear to be
particularly concerned about placing
additional regulatory costs on the
financial industry and particularly
banks for example for no
good reason all bank holding companies
with fifty billion dollars in or more in
assets were designated by statute as one
of those cities which meant that they
were going to be subject to much more
stringent regulation now a fifty billion
dollar bank holding company is not a
systemic Lee important financial
institution if it fails that will not
bring down the rest of the economy
if we talk about a trillion or a two
trillion dollar bank yes we might be
talking about such an institution but
not a fifty billion dollar institution
and yet those were all made subject to
the stringent regulation by the Fed
which of course increases their costs
making it more difficult from there them
to make loans but it was for the
smallest thanks the ten billion dollar
or smaller banks which are called
community banks where most of the
regulation was most hurtful because it
is only the small banks that have the
most difficulty with this regulation if
you're a very large bank you have many
compliance officials you have many
lawyers they can help you deal with this
but the small banks have the problem of
having to stretch this the regulatory
costs over a smaller base of assets a
study by the Government Accountability
Office identified seven dodd-frank
titles which increased the costs or the
competitive burdens for community banks
the GAO included as its small banks or
community banks the those of ten billion
dollars or less as of 2015 well let me
say this there are approximately 5000
community banks in the United States
that is banks with 10 billion or less in
assets that's a rather large number when
compared to the larger banks there are
98 banks with more than 10 billion
dollars just 98
and 39 with assets of more than fifty
billion dollars so the community banks
are the heart of our banking industry in
this country and for good reason because
in this country most of the growth comes
from the startup level that's where
that's where the innovative skills of
American entrepreneurs first come into
place ironically then although that is
there's been great concern in Congress
about the financial advantages of the
too big to fail banks the heavy
regulations of dodd-frank have have
fallen largely on the smallest banks and
indeed Jamie Dimon the chair of the
JPMorgan Chase has referred to
regulation as a moat that reduced
competition from his smaller competitors
because they had so much more regulation
to deal with in relation to the size of
their assets part of the reason that
small banks have been losing market
share is that is because of the decline
in their numbers and the and because of
acquisitions by larger banks both of
these can be attributed to dodd-frank
many community banks are selling out to
the larger institutions which can
operate more favorably and more
profitably in this high regulation
business the the chartering of new banks
which at one time averaged about 100 per
year declined to less than three per
year by 2010 there is almost certainly
this is almost certainly attributable to
the squeeze on profits as a result of
increased regulation if existing
community banks can't make a go of it
why would anyone start a new bank and
that's exactly what has happened
another element causing difficulties for
small banks is the narrative underlying
the dodd-frank act in this false story
as I Hearst a little bit at the
beginning the financial crisis was
caused by insufficient regulation of the
financial industry particularly banks
since
bank regulators and particularly bank
examiners took this to heart and they
came out and started insisting on all
kinds of new regulations for small banks
and successfully impose those
regulations on these small institutions
so they have had difficulty making loans
to guess what small business the small
business credit survey of 12 Federal
Reserve banks recently showed that 61%
of small firms experienced credit
challenge challenges of various kinds
during the last 12 months with 44% of
all small firms reporting credit
unavailability or difficulty finding
credit for expansion growing firms firms
that are succeeding and satisfying their
customers are exactly those that should
be able to get credit yet only a little
over half of these firms were able to
meet their credit needs these are
certainly small banks and I'm sorry
small firms because almost all were
seeking loans of about $100,000 which is
obviously something that only a small
firm would be seeking the credit of
credit restriction for small firms had a
disproportionate effect on employment in
this country and that's why over the
last nine years or so we have had so
much difficulty with finding jobs for
people throughout the throughout the
United States the share of jobs created
by different groups is roughly the share
of their total employment but studies
have shown an important exception in in
one context and that is the contribution
of startup firms they account for much
more proportionately than they are among
the number of firms for example startup
firms created about three and a half
million new jobs according to a study
done about what happened in
two thousand five three and a half
million new jobs in that year
in contrast every other kind of firm
bigger than a start-up except the oldest
firms exhibited net declines in new jobs
during 2005 so it is first the startups
that are having the most difficulty
getting financing now this is a major
cause of the week jobs recovery since
the financial crisis in 2014 two
researchers that the Federal Reserve
used data in Bank call reports to assess
whether there is a difference all right
okay back one okay to set to assess
whether there is a difference between
large banks and community banks in
business lending following the financial
crisis they wrote total outstanding
loans to businesses by commercial banks
dropped off substantially large loans
began to rebound in the third quarter of
2010 and eventually return to their
previous growth pattern you can see that
right here but loans to small firms
continued to decline here we can see the
continuing rise of loans of more than 1
million dollars those are two the larger
firms with a continuing decline of loans
to small firms further much of the drop
in small business loans outstanding was
evident at community banks themselves
here we can see the sharp drop-off in
small Bank commercial and industrial
loans where large bank loans have
remained relatively steady so again that
fits in with my thesis about what
actually happened in the financial after
the financial crisis and dodd-frank
dodd-frank actually caused a substantial
decline in loans to small banks loans
from small banks to small
business and that has caused the weak
weak recovery and the weak jobs picture
in the United States it's not generally
understood that the United States has a
sharply bifurcated credit market
according to the Small Business
Administration in 2010 there were 28
million small businesses in the United
States defined as firms with fewer than
500 employees of these five and a half
million were employers the rest were
small small proprietorships moms and
pops I guess you'd call them with no
formal employees at the same time there
were 18,000 500 of the largest
businesses in this country less than 1%
of all employers with 500 employees or
more these two classes and businesses
have very different sources of credit
the larger businesses see if we have a
slide on that yep
the larger businesses have access to the
capital markets and that blue line is
how the capital markets have been
financing credit for business in the
United States the red line is and the
dotted line is what the banks have been
financing you can see that the capital
markets are much more significant in
financing business than the banks are so
when you have the banks making fewer
loans then you have the the institutions
the companies that are dependent on
banks getting less credit and being
unable to make the use of the credit in
the form of hiring people and so forth
so what we have seen then is that the
small businesses in the United States
who don't have access to the capital
markets according to a recent goldman
sachs study those small firms during the
period of the last year's after that
after the financial crisis they reduce
their employment by about 700 employees
over the course of each year whereas the
larger firms that have access to first
the biggest banks who are doing quite
well and the the capital markets
increase their employment by about 2,500
employees each month or each relevant
period where the study was made so they
were they were increasing their
employment while the smaller companies
were declining in in their employment
during this period all as a result of
the fact that smaller financial
institutions were unable to make the
kinds of loans that they had always been
making to smaller businesses and the
smaller businesses in turn could not
then grow themselves and employ so that
to me is the reason the dodd-frank act
has been such a disaster for this
country's economy and why it should be
repealed and never replaced thank you
[Applause]
it's a great thank you very much Paul
Atkins here and thank you Chris for that
really nice introduction earlier it's a
pleasure to be here at Hillsdale a
conference which always the fire just
kills me a lot and I have to admit I
made a real grave mistake when my eldest
son and I were out looking at colleges
when we visited Hillsdale in February of
I think it was 2011 there'd be this huge
snowstorm and half the town was out of
lights but and so there's no mystery ye
my son I guess chose to go to South
Carolina as a school at Furman instead
of Bill's they all so anyway with my
youngest son now coming along will make
a better decision maybe go visit
Hillsdale in a spring with birds
chirping and things like that it might
yield a better impression but it's a
real pleasure to be here with you all
and on this topic and it's you know it's
a pleasure to follow Peter who has done
such a great job through his career of
critiquing regulation at the American
Enterprise Institute Peter started what
was the shadow SEC he called it shadow
financial services forum and so when I
was a SEC as a commissioner it was
always great to know that I was back
stocked by Peter and his colleagues with
good critiques good ideas what not to
push back on some of the more
problematic ideas that seemed to emanate
from various parts of Washington and
though of course that was in the good
old days before dodd-frank was adopted
in in enacted in 2010 and so what I
wanted to do was spend a little bit of
time and I want to expand a little bit
on what Peter was talking about as some
of the costs of dodd-frank but then also
talk about you know what to replace it
with I agree with Peters thesis that it
shouldn't be replaced because it wasn't
really needed at the beginning but there
are a lot of things that I think
Congress can do that would help in the
Finance
Services area of barnacles that have
grown up since over the last 70 or 80
years with our statutory system and and
should be addressed so we'll get into
that a little bit but let's first I do
want to take exception to what Chris was
saying you came up with a lot over the
few fewer pages of dodd-frank than what
I've been you know citing as 2319 pages
is what my count was it was a committee
print that the and it gets kind of
compressed when it gets out into the
Federal Register at 800 some but that's
still a lot when you compare it to say
the Securities Act of 1933 or star
beings Oxley which came around in there
in 2002 but you know basically
dodd-frank unfortunately was a travesty
of legislative process it was rushed
through pretty much on a party-line vote
there are hardly any hearings about
really major provisions of it and it was
subject to really poor draftsmanship I
mean really egregious things like for
example in complete sentences completely
wrong cross references and so things
about the statute don't make any sense
and like you probably know and at least
lawyers should know in most of Congress
of course is peopled by lawyers that
though the staff and the member level
you know words make a difference and
even commas make a difference when
judges come along to to look and try to
adjudicate issues later on
and unfortunately dodd-frank is just a
complete mess in that regard
dodd-frank established 13 new agencies
and and offices and so it's no wonder
that the costs have soared and it
eliminated one the office of Thrift
Supervision which looked after savings
and loans but of course after 2008 there
were really no more savings and loans to
look after so dodd-frank put the OTS out
of its misery but never fear all those
employees of OTS were well taken care of
they all found jobs elsewhere in the
federal government and so of course you
all paid for that so anyway
it you know it's it's just being a
problem from the beginning and
dodd-frank was really aimed there are
many provisions that were aimed at
favorite constituencies so trial lawyers
the labor unions and other sorts of
groups like that of the majority that
voted for dodd-frank took care of their
own so Peter went through how dodd-frank
hurt the economy and focused on lending
and especially small business lending
and that chart number two that Peter
used I think tells the whole story of
how loans of greater than a million
dollars you know went right back
soaring up and loans up by forty percent
if you actually look at that chart and
figure it out
loans of under a million dollars so that
really means people who are trying to
start businesses a watch shark tank or
anything like that and you see how
people are not really asking for that
much money to get up and going with
their new business they mortgaged their
houses if they can or other things like
that
so those loans below a million dollars
having gone down and then leveling off I
think tells the whole story that Delta
is pretty marked between the that the
bottom line and the top line so that's
that tells the story of why new business
startups and entrepreneurial ism during
the Obama years was really was really
problematic so a few years ago I was
speaking at a conference down in Florida
and was preceded by Austin Goolsbee who
had been the chairman of President
Obama's Council of Economic Advisers and
he gave a pretty good speech this was
right before dinner or right after
dinner I guess it was and he was jovial
with a crowd and he talked about how at
CEA they're back at the White House they
were concerned about how the economy
wasn't rebounding because they had
expected a V recovery and then they were
looking for you and then they were
hoping for a w he went through all the
different letters of the alphabet and
even the Greek alphabet and they
couldn't really come up with an
explanation
and then we bantered with a crowd a bit
and took questions and then so I raised
my hand and posed what turned out to be
the final question so I said well thank
you very much for your talk and in but
we've seen all these statutes that have
come out so dodd-frank and the
Affordable Care Act in fat can all these
others that had among them you know
thousands of pages of statutory language
and then as they were being implemented
by the various agencies tens of
thousands of more pages of regulation
and I started saying he cut me off and
he said I know what you're gonna say
you're gonna ask me you know has all
that regulation had a downward effect on
on the recovery he said absolutely not
and then he reeled off a couple of
citations to studies and I wasn't quick
enough to write it down and with that he
said thank you very much good night so
obviously I pooped the party I'm happy
to be the party pooper but obviously I
also you know hit a nerve and I think
that even people there in that
administration realized that this
runaway freight train of regulatory
overproduction you know was having you
know downward effect and so with respect
to small business startups and in the
economy coming back up the regulatory
costs I think as dodd-frank you know are
really to blame and then also with
respect to the sarbanes-oxley Act which
was adopted back as I said back in 2002
and if you look at just some of the the
facts that Peter covered a little bit
but we today we have half the number of
banks that we had back in 2008 and
that's not because the banks went out of
business for bad business reasons
obviously some of them did they were
overextended with loans or insolvent but
most were not but there was a an
affirmative policy by the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation thinking
that the United States is over banked
and they had a policy to merge banks out
of existence and most of these community
banks like Peter
fourth are the ones that loan to
entrepreneurs and startup businesses and
then during that time they had a policy
against approving new banks up until now
only about five new banks have been
approved since 2009 since the Obama
folks came into power and so that tells
you a story there about you know the
effect on small businesses and you look
at the capital markets today we have
half the number of public companies that
we did public twenty years ago
that means public companies that you can
buy or sell on the stock exchange and
the initial public offering market is
really in the tank and that is because
again of regulatory costs that become a
public company is really very expensive
and so because of all the compliance
issues that you have to deal with and so
the IPO market 20 years ago there were
seven hundred some companies that went
public back in 1996 last year a hundred
and some now that's not to say seven
hundred is the right number but I can
tell you that a hundred some is not you
know what it should be so all those
things have had an effect on the United
States marketplace and the vitality of
our economy and that's what the new
administration has set out to try to
correct and so from the beginning the
president has been talking about that
and the new chairman of the SEC who's
the corporation finance lawyer from New
York who's a great guy you know is
setting about to try to to deal with
that so hopefully that some of these
activities despite the fact that
dodd-frank is still on the books will
will you know pay some dividends if let
me go through a little bit more of
dodd-frank and a little bit of detail
apart from the negative effects because
the philosophy of it I think is also
extremely problematic and one that
really speaks to why it needs to be
repealed so from the beginning
dodd-frank
pursued as Peter said thus narrative
that it was you know the evil wall
street's that was the one that drove the
cause of the financial crisis if we only
regulate Wall Street Birgit under
control then things will will be a lot
better so the first title of dodd-frank
title one is called financial stability
so it was the whole idea was if you get
enough smart people in a room and you
get enough information and they can peer
in their crystal balls they will be able
to prick bubbles before they start well
Hayek wrote in his last book it was
called the fatal conceit and so he
basically decried this type of
propensity of Washington and other other
governments around the world basically
for that that you know we need people
who are smarter than the average bear to
figure out how to do things that the
market is more equipped to do and so the
dodd-frank set up this financial
stability Oversight Council which Peter
alluded to the eff sock is called and
they have a power to designate
particular banks or other non banks and
institutions as being systemically
important so they're called systemically
important financial institution this is
and it's abbreviated to si fi now some
people pronounce that sippy I refused to
do that and Barney Frank said that you
know it sounds like a venereal disease
and I think he's probably right about
that but I would argue that si fi should
be pronounced the same as H I fi
hi-fi or Wi-Fi which I'd pronounce as or
si fi then should be pronounced as
sci-fi exactly and that's exactly what
this whole regime is built upon science
fiction as far as getting these people
to declare these particular institutions
as systemically important right well
thank you so they like Peter said they
went about to evade we're required by
statute to declare the big banks is
Syfy's and then they went about to
declare some market utilities like the
Depository Trust & Clearing Corporation
and other things like that as as Syfy's
then they looked at non-bank financial
institutions GE Capital so Jeff Immelt
was so infuriated that Federal Reserve
examiners wanted to come in and sit in
mommy G's board meeting that that's when
he said we get rid of GE Capital as fast
as we can and then they declared AIG you
know an insurance company Prudential
another insurance company
MetLife they declared a sci-fi and that
life was the only one that was brave
enough Steve Kandarian the CEO to fight
back and sue over that and actually won
in District Court in Washington and
that's one thing write your Congressman
right the secretary of the treasury
Stephen venusian because the Obama
administration took that decision that
was a very good one by the Federal
District Judge and appealed it up to the
circuit court in DC and right now that's
pending before the the Treasury and so
secretary munition is going to have to
make a decision here coming up they
picked it down the road of that whether
or not to continue that appeal I say
drop the appeal let it stand because
basically the judge said that the whole
construct of this F sock is problematic
that in their declaration of these
various companies to be Syfy's they just
had a very flawed process and and it
needs to be redone
so hopefully secretary munition will
decide not to pursue that appeal so
anyway so those are some of the issues
but as they were looking at declaring
other things like asset managers with
the Fed which was behind a lot of this
designation process of F sock was after
is control over your mutual fund over
your 401k plan and over your IRA because
of what they want to do by declaring
asset management
and activity being systemically
important is being able to say the asset
managers in time of crisis thou shalt
not sell a particular type of security
in order to calm the market and because
they're afraid of people just dumping
their securities and fleeing and we all
know if you are in the market place and
you tell somebody that you may not flee
that just makes people even more
panicked and they wonderfully faster
than possible then than they would have
before and so I think it's just a very
short step then from being able to tell
somebody that thou shalt not sell
something to be able to say like they do
in Argentina thou shalt buy something in
order to support the price and with a
rationale well we'll try to you know
keep our banks solvent by supporting
their the reserves and their capital
structures of what they have under
girding their their capital so that's a
fear that I have and people who say well
you know that can't happen in the United
States all I have to do is point to the
tarp program and how they told every
single bank or most of the big banks
back then that you know you must take
tarp money even if you don't need it so
there are all sorts of things that I
fear in the future if this sort of power
remains for the government so dodd-frank
is a lot of other things that are
problematic you know they can Feder
touched on the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau there are a lot of
things in this in the titles that deal
with the SEC for example that give
administrative law judges huge new
authority to which I think is
unconstitutional and there's some
challenges up to the Supreme Court with
respect to these ALJ's and their
authority to be able to to find people
in companies and even to take their
livelihoods away without without all the
protections that one has in normal
federal courts so a lot of things that
need to be done with respect to
dodd-frank and repealing it but what do
we do you know if we can't repeal it and
so that's one thing that you know we're
looking for next year as far
you know Senate seats that are up and
hopefully we'll be able to increase the
number of Republicans in the Senate
because right now and then I told this
to the president or it gave this analogy
to the president early on after the
election that you know if we are not
able to get statutes through I compared
the regulations to sandcastles so the
Obama administration erected all these
sandcastles
of regulations that now with our tide
like at the beach we're coming in our
tides is coming in and we'll be able to
wash away these regulations because
we'll be taking over the regulatory
agencies and then will erect our own
sand castles and unless we can undergird
those sand castles with rebar and
concrete they will be washed away
inevitably in the next hopefully twenty
years or whenever it might be when the
next tide comes in from the other side
and so unless we can get statutes
through and then also get that supported
with a good litigation strategy with
good opinions coming out of the courts
it's going to be problematic
so the House of Representatives last
year or past or this year I guess it was
passed the what's called a financial
choice Act which is based upon market
principles and trying to you know have a
goal of repealing dodd-frank and ending
bank bailouts and thing too big to fail
trying to bring in more market-based
type of practices into our regulatory
structure more transparency open up the
Fed you know audit the Fed except for
monetary policy but all of that
transparency I think is a good thing
because you cannot have democratic
institutions that operate in an opaque
non transparent way that's just not the
way things should operate in our society
so with that let me stop I'm happy to
talk on that I should let Nicole speak
to us maybe in french-canadian and see
if even those of us who understand
French can understand that but no but
anyway was a pleasure to talk to you I'm
happy to take questions afterwards thank
you
[Applause]
good afternoon Congress is not going to
repeal or replace dodd-frank and that is
not because Congress is irrational
rather it's because dodd-frank is doing
exactly what it was designed to do seven
years ago when President Obama signed it
into law now you may be thinking wait a
minute that's not true
I know my dodd-frank pretty well I'm
sure you've all read quite a bit about
it over the past seven years and you may
believe that dodd-frank had two purposes
one was to end too big to fail as the
president said when he signed it this
law will end taxpayer bailouts once and
for all and to to protect consumers from
predatory behavior
now clearly dodd-frank has not ended too
big to fail before 2008 the country had
seven mega banks and they each had a
market share of about seven percent
today the country has has six mega banks
because one of them bought another one
and each of their market share has
increased to 11 percent between 10 and
11 percent and moreover the dodd-frank
philosophy is not to allow for failure
by cushing cushioning the economy from
that failure in other words in a healthy
economy a financial institution even a
very large global financial institution
with several trillion dollars worth of
assets should be able to fail and the
economy should be able to withstand that
that is not what dodd-frank did in
dodd-frank contrary to that free-market
philosophy tries to prevent all
financial failure which
should be impossible now on consumer
protection did dodd-frank succeed in
protecting consumers and I'll give you a
two-word answer to that question Wells
Fargo Wells Fargo before the
presidential election last year it was
it was revealed that the bank had
systemic ly created three to four
million fake accounts this is in effect
identity theft and it wasn't just a few
rogue employees looking to increase
their bonuses this is a systemic failure
to protect against a risk that
responsible corporate executives should
have known would arise with the wrong
incentives and the wrong compliance
procedures what has happened to Wells
Fargo since then well not very much of
course its executives have to go through
the ritual congressional testimony top
people have had to resign but they've
set aside a billion dollars in provision
for future fines that's a very small
percentage of their profits and they
will most likely continue to be one of
the nation's large financial
institutions despite this very real
systemic failure now if Congress had
wanted to end taxpayer bailouts and
protect consumers there were easy
straightforward ways to go about doing
that the way to prevent taxpayer
bailouts is to allow for financial firms
to fail the way to allow financial firms
to fail is to protect the economy when
those failures happen and the way to do
that is done through higher capital
requirements in other words if my bank
has ten dollars in assets it has to have
a certain percentage of those assets in
non borrowed money that means first if
there is a downturn hopefully that
cushion of non borrowed money should
protect the bank to some extent from
loan losses and other
decisions but if the bank has made such
bad decisions that this non borrowed
money is used up if then can go bankrupt
without taking down the rest of the
economy why is that because you want
your capital requirements to be
consistent as well that the government
only says what is the percentage level
of capital that these institutions have
to hold it is the financial institutions
job to decide what kind of investments
are risky and what kind of investments
are not risky as long as they hold this
particular level of capital that way
financial institutions will make all
different types of mistakes rather than
make the same mistake at the same time
as they did in the years leading up to
2008 now if in in doing these things
will automatically protect consumers
because a higher capital cushion results
in less debt overall for the economy
which is good for consumers particularly
poor consumers who simply cannot handle
the debt burden that they've taken on
not just in recent years but over more
than three decades now this gets to why
would we do
dodd-frank when dodd-frank is not simply
simple and straightforward dodd-frank is
difficult and complex and the Congress
people and their staffers and their
lobbyists are not stupid if they wanted
to achieve these goals they would know
how to do them but these are not
dodd-frank real purpose dodd-frank
purpose is to maintain a private-sector
economy that is addicted to cheap
private sector debt and that has been
addicted to cheap private sector debt
for more than three decades so we'll go
back in time a little bit what happened
starting 35 years ago wage stagnation
I'm sure you've heard a lot about this
and the time leading up to Trump's
election and began to make itself
apparent among the working class 35
years ago
if
were the breadwinner in the 40%
percentile of households you made about
$41,000 a year this is your person who's
graduated from high school has a skill
made a reasonably good living today that
same household breadwinner makes the
same amount of money after inflation
forty-one thousand dollars a year so the
working class household has not made any
real wage gains over thirty five years
there are many reasons for this lou
dobbs mentioned some of them last night
from the competition from trade deals to
the the ripping up of the iron curtain
which gave the West billions more
potential workers as competition in over
the past thirty five years not only
Eastern Europe but China being a part of
that and opening their their economy to
competition and family formation is also
a reason for this the reasons can be
debated and discussed but the reality is
there so what happened when wages
started to stagnate you would think that
consumer spending would have gone down
prices would have gone down that this
would have had a impact on the real
economy but that was not true and why is
that because people substituted debt
income for wage income and this was
encouraged by the government's on a
bipartisan basis because it allowed the
governing class to avoid a lot of the
difficult questions that people have
been raising just over the past few
years so from 1980 to 2008
you can see how debt became a much
greater part of people's day-to-day
lives in the numbers over these years
mortgage debt quadrupled after inflation
again credit card and auto debt nearly
tripled the population only went up by
30 percent
the mechanism of pushing out the main
mechanism for pushing out all of
debt to the average consumer was houses
you may think that mortgage borrowing
the the purpose of a mortgage loan is to
purchase a house and then to pay that
debt down over time so that when you
have retired you have this asset to hand
down to your family or to sell and
finance your retirement but starting in
the late 80s early 90s
houses were a mechanism to get other
consumer debt down to the borrower Alan
Greenspan and James Kennedy did a study
that said starting in 1991 through 2005
people used home equity loans to take
out more than half a trillion dollars
every year from their houses they use
that to finance their consumer spending
in other words someone owns a house
they've been trying to pay the mortgage
but suddenly they find themselves with
$10,000 in credit card debt
they they had to pay for school for for
a child not not college but high school
or elementary school they had a medical
expense or their day-to-day spending
simply does not keep up with their
day-to-day expenses these are not trips
to Europe these are this is not blowout
spending this is a compilation of
consumer debt because people are not
keeping up with cost and so what does
someone do when they run into the debt
that makes them uncomfortable they would
go and refinance their house take that
money out pay down the credit card debt
and start over now after 2008 it went
really after 2007 the markets tried to
correct this if what was left of the
free financial market said there's just
too much private sector debt in the US
it to a lesser extent in Britain and and
the rest of the West people have
borrowed all that they really can they
can't borrow any more so let's stop this
and figure out how to fix this economy
what did the government do in response
not only the US government but Western
governments are
the worlds as well they tried their best
to keep the system going they didn't
want a change whether a gradual change
or a sudden change and gradual change is
always better but if you don't allow for
gradual change you will get a sudden
change they didn't want to change from a
consumer debt based economy to a more
productive wage income based economy so
they as Peter mentioned the Federal
Reserve and other central banks began
quantitative evening tried quantitative
easing try to push more debt into the
private-sector economy but the other
issue was what to do about financial
regulation people were clamoring for new
financial regulation
the answer was dodd-frank so what do you
do if you have to do financial
regulation but you don't really want to
do financial regulation the first this
is a this is a puzzle why is this bill
so large well first of all they they
couldn't touch Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac because these are the mechanisms to
get cheap debt through housing to the
American public so we have this
dodd-frank law despite its many many
pages it doesn't say very much about
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac the second
thing you really couldn't touch consumer
credit so dodd-frank it doesn't it
maintains a system of waiting which
allows financial firms to rate
securitized consumer credit as not risky
what does that mean it means in capital
requirements although capital
requirements are higher something that
is rated not whiskey not risky it
doesn't require a financial institution
to put capital behind it so if I am a
financial firm I'm securitizing credit
card debt I I sell this debt on to the
global capital markets I don't have to
put a capital behind that these
financial firms can still
be a conduit for cheap global consumer
credit from the average American to the
global capital markets and so we can't
touch the two major issues that cause
this problem housing that credit card
debt and auto loan debt so what can we
do well a lot of delay and diversion
dodd-frank required 390 rules by the
time the Trump administration was
inaugurated only 75% of them were dumb
21% of them were not even proposed and
many of the rules that are completed are
very vague the Volcker rule for example
this alone is a thousand and eighty
pages this is this is not part of the
official page count of the dodd-frank
law but you can read these pages and you
won't know what banks are supposed to do
what what is considered speculative
trading that is prohibited by the votes
of a rule and what is considered market
making or hedging and no one can really
tell you whether at a bank or at a
regulator now the other part of
dodd-frank that does exist versus what
they should have done that doesn't exist
is the orderly liquidation Authority
this is a way to maintain too big to
fail so that these large financial firms
can continue to be a conduit of cheap
consumer credit what what does orderly
liquidation Authority mean it means if a
JPMorgan Chase or a Citigroup has
financial trouble and seems to be on the
verge of failing the government doesn't
allow it to go through bankruptcy which
has features important checks and
balances it is the judicial branch that
oversees the liquidation or the
recapitalisation of the company so
there's some independence but in orderly
liquidation by contrast it's largely
handled by the executive branch a
failing bank can be seized by the
executive branch of the government and
it can be run for three years by the
executive
branch of the federal government if they
need two more years they just have to
tell Congress that they want to run it
for five years so it's interesting when
many people on both sides are no sides
of the political aisle say I worry that
Trump he's he's doing irresponsible
things with the power that he has well
if you think that Trump is irresponsible
or any presidents is irresponsible why
would you put him or her ultimately in
charge of a bank with trillions of
dollars worth of assets for five years
but that is what dodd-frank allows and
in in running a bank for five years the
government's can favor certain creditors
over others pay off certain derivatives
and other transactions while letting
others take losses there's no real
consistency here it is it is what
officials in the executive branch think
is necessary to maintain financial
stability now the the implications of
this so far is that from Congress's
perspective it has succeeded that
consumer debt has continued to increase
it went down from 2008 to 2014 but it
has gone up again and and much of that
decrease was more mortgage write-offs
it wasn't the gradual change that our
economy needs now today credit card debt
is back up to where it was
before 2008 and a lot of people consider
that to be a success for the economy
auto loans you go out to a parking lot
everyone has an SUV that's worth $40,000
or more they did not buy that they took
out a loan 0% financing and when that
SUV is passed it's useful life they will
still owe money on that car and they
will give it back to the bank having to
either make a payment or roll it over
this is not a sustainable way to run an
auto industry and the hundreds of
thousands of middle-class jobs that that
depend on it
and what's what's going to happen next
well
Trump as as both Peter and Paul mentions
that the president has created a
commission to figure out how to fix
dodd-frank and they put out two reports
so far with some some pretty good if
very incremental ideas that they can do
through the executive branch rather than
legislation but just to illustrate the
absurdity of the law and the attempts to
address the law who is in charge of
figuring out how to fix dodd-frank it's
the financial stability Oversight
Commission which is itself as both Peter
and Paul mentioned as well a creation of
dodd-frank the f sock is not going to
recommend getting rid of itself it's
very very unlikely so what what should
the president which should Congress do
the Congress should repeal the Volcker
Rule it really doesn't do much of
anything at all and it maintains this
philosophy that the government should
decide what's risky or not not these
financial institutions and they should
certainly repeal the orderly liquidation
Authority because again this is this is
prevent failure rather than allow for a
free market economy to withstand failure
but I would be surprised if either one
of these things were to happen thank you
thank you much we have time for
questions and there are microphones
around the room so please raise your
hand and someone will come to you I
think two of you mentioned about the
quantitative easy now the Federal
Reserve to the quantitative easing has
increases assets by about three trillion
and they're going to reduce that asset
over time how would it impact the
economy can that be compared to the
dodd-frank impact on the economy is this
mic working yes I guess it is now I am a
lawyer not an economist but I can make a
guess about what would happen with
quantitative reasoning first of all much
of the quantitative easing was done
through the purchase of Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac securities they were taken
off the market went into the Fed's
balance sheet and when they came off the
market that meant that there was less
competition for US government securities
because Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
securities were backed informally but
known to be backed by the US government
when that happened that caused Treasury
securities to decline in their in their
ass their interest rates so what I think
will be done with with quantitative
easing is they will just allow the
Fannie and Freddie securities that they
bought to run off which means that
people will just pay off their mortgages
and though when when people pay off
their mortgages the assets that are that
back those securities decline the money
comes into the Federal Reserve it will
then be paid over to the Treasury
Department probably but that is that
should not have much of an impact on the
economy Oh
the over the long term if the Fed were
actually to try to liquidate those
securities right now it would have a
major effect on the economy for the
exactly the opposite reason of what I
just talked about because that would
that would make it a glut on the market
all of this knew all of these new
government backed securities coming onto
the market and it would probably cause a
lot of inflation so I think that they
will just hang on for a while and not
make much of a change in that in those
back in that balance sheet but all of
this is subject to a lot of speculation
and concern at the Fed so it's a guess
on my part well I just
and also I grew a Peter but but one
thing you have to remember about the Fed
is that there's very little transparency
into what exactly it has so that's why
when people talk about you know the need
to have a real audit of the Fed you know
I think in many respects that's correct
if you look at the fine print of I think
Deloitte and - she's the auditor of the
Fed at the current time but there's a
lot of disclaimer as to what their
process is they don't follow GAAP you
know generally accepted accounting
principles they follow the feds own
rules as to how they value an account
how they put together their financial
statements so we don't really know what
they have and they've been buying and
selling US Treasury securities and as
Peter says other GSE security so you
know who knows what the real values are
and of course the Fed is the ultimate
inside trader in these markets you know
they're in there and they make some of
the markets and they you know through
their buying and selling they can affect
the the prices and also their profit or
or loss on their trades so I mean you
can tell probably which way they usually
go on whether it's profit or loss
so anyway so it'll be interesting to see
now that new personnel will be coming
into the Board of Governors I'm looking
forward to maybe a perhaps a different
approach yes I guess this question is
for mr. woloson when you were giving
your a list of things that I guess
mainly happened under the Obama
administration the Affordable Care Act
and those other things I was wondering
if you factored in the cash for clunkers
bailout so to speak and also the
multiple extensions that were done on
the unemployment insurance that lasted
for some people up to three two or three
years I did not include those but you
could they were much smaller than the
other things in terms of their impact on
the economy I thought cash for clunkers
was to help the automobile market
recover a little bit by taking these
clunkers off the market and then and so
people would buy new cars and the the
other those other programs also were
modestly helpful to some people but what
at the point I was really trying to make
was simply that here were these gigantic
influxes of cash into the market ACA
Affordable Care Act cash pouring out to
the insurance companies and through them
to the healthcare industry the the eight
over eight hundred billion dollars to
sprinkle on to shovel-ready projects
that weren't apparently shovel-ready
that didn't work these are major amounts
of money and they had no real effect on
the course of the economy the economy
did not recover and in fact plenty of
studies they didn't have a chance to
mention this of course that plenty of
studies have shown that when the
government is active in dealing with a
downturn in the economy it causes the
the recover
to be much slower and it's it's been so
clear for years that that has been
happening that we we we really don't
seem to learn from these the the the the
past there's been a very good book out
that showed that the that the this is
the James grant book that shows that the
recession really depression in the year
nineteen twenty was huge but it lasted
only a year because the government did
nothing the government had no policy at
that point and the the economy bounced
back and we then had the Roaring
Twenties after that I was wondering is
there any chance that the Consumer
Financial Protection Board will be
repealed because it seems to be very
unconstitutional I can do it if you I
don't think it will be repealed and the
the avenue for big change would be
through the court system but it's going
back to the point about being concerned
about President Trump being ultimately
in charge of a large bank for five years
the Democrats and Republicans who are
also concerned about checking any one
branches of branch of government's power
the provision that the sole person in
charge of the CFPB his term out last the
president but he has no Commission to
keep him in check every other government
agency it's either one or the other that
you can have a term as a commissioner
that outlasts the presidential term but
that means there's a commission of five
to seven people that that's how the SEC
works that's how the FTC works so that
one person does not have
this this power that is supposed to be
insulated from politics or you can be
solely in charge but you serve at the
pleasure of the president and can be
fired by the president that CFPB is the
only one that is not one or the other
it's one person whose term outlast the
president's but when mr. Cordray's term
is up Trump is going to be able to
nominate his own person so you would
think and that and that person sir a
term intern will outlast the next
election so if you were hoping that
Elizabeth Warren becomes president after
Trump well without big changes to the
CFPB either through legislation or
through the court process she would not
be able to nominate her own person she
would be stuck with the Trump person for
half of her her first term so these
things have worked out well for the
people who signs dodd-frank into law but
they can be used against them which is
why we should we should stick to these
democratic principles of checks and
balances even if we don't like the
short-term outcome in some cases yep I
just and just to throw a couple more
points in so yeah I you know anything
that's entitled the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau you have a political
issue of whether or not you know whether
it's possible to repeal it even the
financial choice Act that passed the
house doesn't provide for the repeal the
CFPB but like Nicole was saying you know
Institutes the Commission it puts it on
the budget of the US so that there's
more control over Congress you know I
think what they should do is you know
repeal it and then put it back into the
to the various agencies as it was done
before but but anyway there are two
tests that are coming up in Congress
that will be interesting to see what
happens
Richard Cordray who is a director pushed
through a rule basically getting rid of
mandatory arbitration clauses
contracts for various consumer financial
products so that's up before the
Congress now under the congressional
review act as you know Congress for the
first time really in a systematic way
has gone over and thrown out a number of
regulations that were adopted you know
the final year of the Obama
administration so now this one that was
just adopted by the CFPB a few months
ago you know is up we'll see if we have
the votes and in the Senate to overturn
that one and then just the other day the
CFPB adopted another rule regarding
payday loans basically putting that
industry out of business and so we'll
see what happens in this in Congress
with respect to that so that's a good
test to see what you know what the
politics are one of the things that over
here one of the things that is not
talked about very much in dodd-frank or
other types of legislation is the
ethical impact of this government
legislation in this particular case to
ethical areas stick out one something we
call the moral hazard something that
appears to have a short-term benefit but
in the long run has negative
consequences and I wonder if some some
of you would address that the negative
long-term consequences not only of
bailouts but of other areas to try to
protect people and businesses in the
short run the second ethical issue which
i think is even more important is
indebtedness do we want to encourage
continued indebtedness I know we're a
consumer economy
but again you know what the Bible has to
say the borrower is the slave of the
lender and it's not prohibiting
borrowing but it's warning against it
and so I think you know as we try to
encourage more and more borrowing more
and more indebtedness we are doing a
disservice to people and in the future
they're going to feel the problem there
so I'd like some of you to comment on
that thank you very much
I'll try to deal with that because I
have talked a lot about the moral hazard
issue when I talk about housing policy
we Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac as I
indicated these two very large mortgage
companies their business was buying
mortgages that were made by banks and
other lenders and then they would hold
these mortgages and turn them into
mortgage-backed securities and sell them
to the public with a government with us
what was essentially a government
guarantee on them so here's where the
moral hazard comes in because with the
government guarantee no one cared about
the quality of the underlying mortgages
and as a result we had a period of time
between about 1992 and 2008 when
terrible mortgages were being made in
the United States Fannie and Freddie
actually wanted these terrible mortgages
because they were required by the
government to buy mortgages that were
made to people who were below median
income and those people could not come
up with the down payments and and have
the stable incomes that enable those
mortgages to be good quality investments
but nobody cared who cared because in
fact anyone who was buying a Fannie and
Freddie security and many many people
did they said well I don't care what
what is underlying these securities
because the government is backing them
and as a result that's where moral
hazard is exactly the problem and that
is that it allows things like
transactions like this to occur where we
had well five almost five trillion
dollars in assets in the form of
mortgages in the United States of which
about a little more than half were
subprime mortgages that fell apart as
soon as housing prices began to decline
in
seven that's moral hazard that's why we
ought to get the government out of not
only the housing finance system but we
ought to get it out of a lot of other
backing a lot of other debt in the
United States we've just heard about
floods in various places I think there
was some place nearby where there were
floods um can't remember exactly but the
the federal flood insurance program is
all full of moral hazard people are able
to buy homes on the beaches right on the
beaches even though there's going to be
a flood because the the federal flood
insurance program is very weak in terms
of what it guarantees and so it's
creating more moral hazard people taking
more risks that they wouldn't otherwise
take if they did not have the
government's backing telling them that
the risk is going to be managed in the
future I would
I would add only that another moral
hazard if you will is this social hazard
that many people are still surprised
that President Trump won the election
but a big reason why he won goes back to
2008 that people were so angry at these
bailouts and at the perception which was
a correct perception of unfairness that
if I run a small business and I have bad
luck my business will fail but if I run
a large Bank I have bad luck the
government will step in and rescue my
bank and maybe I'll lose my job but I've
still got tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions - to take home with
me after I've lost my job and people
could see that this is not a free-market
financial system but the establishment
Republicans if you go back to the
debates and this is by the way this
starts in 2012 and and Romney would
never repudiate the financial bailouts
he was given many opportunities to do so
but he just would never do it it just
was not in his character to say anything
critical about a bank when it's not
being critical of a bank to say they
should fail if they make decisions that
lead to their failure same thing in 2016
these candidates were afraid to be
critical of large financial institutions
and say very clearly that they would
hold them subject to free-market values
and I think the public can understand
that better than the establishment could
and this this created what we have today
a lot of people are unhappy that Trump
won for many different reasons good and
bad but he would not have won if we had
had a free market economy back in 2008
we have time for one more question
yeah I want to continue with this theme
about government creating a distorted
marketplace in which consumers and
businesses
our acting and interacting in fashions
that not only compromised their current
situations but also put the future at
risk and the bottom line is the children
of today are going to be our bankers our
health care workers our investors and we
are setting them up for failure you
talked about the mortgage industry look
at the student loan industry and the
subsidization that's taking place there
that is driven by Sandy Sallie Mae then
you look at the car industry's you speak
about SUVs we're allowing people who are
not credit worthy to buy these huge SUVs
and they're driving them for six months
and then they're turning them in and the
subprime auto loan market is about ready
to fail so it's government incentives in
it the people present themselves as
trying to do well and yet they are
causing not only our own personal wealth
to be put at risk but they're
compromising the futures of our children
how do you respond to that doesn't sound
like good idea you're you're completely
right and this is politics
and the only way we're going to stop
this is if all of you in here or anyone
it agrees with what the lady just said
gets to his or her Congress person and
Senator and says this has really got to
stop people have to take responsibility
for the things in their lives and if
they are if the government is going to
take over the things in their lives and
take responsibility for it
well then eventually we all become
responsible for the irresponsibility of
those people because they've been
encouraged to be irresponsible we've
made them irresponsible so that's it's
the lesson I think that we all have to
learn from when the politicians try to
help people
thank you Peter and the lesson we know
from socialism is that we're all
responsible then no one's responsible so
our time is up so I would like to ask
you to once again thank our
distinguished panelists